It was the night before Christmas the
stockings were hung by the chimney and
the Avengers were fighting a brand new
superpower I'm Santa Claus baby starting
tomorrow unwrap one new episode every day
for nine straight days so who's our bad
guy for a holiday party what could go wrong
it's
[Music] are oh got to admit that's
some solid holiday word [Music] play
there are infinite stories to be told across the
Multiverse
well you got the color of the suit [Music]
right I am
blue [Music] hey is the big man in high rollers
table s but fair warning he does not
like to be buzzed when he's on a hot
streak Hey Howard you how's business well you
know the world's falling apart and I'm running
a casino things are great and speaking of great
waitress could you bring us some small bites for
the reflective woman over here or do you just eat
meab bites what if season 2 streaming tomorrow
welcome back everyone is Charlie there's a brand
new Marvel what if season 2 trailer so we'll break
it all down there's a bunch of Easter eggs here A
bunch of footage and a bunch of big announcements
about the future of the MCU just in general like
what's happening with the next couple of Avengers
movies how they're changing them and how they're
pivoting the MCU just in general to more X-Men
mutant-based stories after Secret Wars in a really
really big way like pivoting away from everything
that you've seen before so it really does feel
like the start of something new instead of just
like the MCU season 50 because there is a bit of
a fatigue problem that happens if you just keep
recycling the same old characters which is where
all the X-Men and the mutant-based characters come
in it's like a completely different vibe if
you're brand new to the channel I'll be doing
what if season 2 episodes for everything just
like I did for season 1 be sure to subscribe
to get them all the difference this year is
that they're actually airing them one per day
for 9 days there'll be Nine episodes total there
are a couple other big things that are happening
between now and the end of the year so I'll try
to do videos for everything as soon as possible
like we have Aquaman 2 coming out this weekend
we have Zack Snider's Rubble Moon I'll do videos
for that stuff too but just really big heads up
on what the schedule's going to be like for the
next week it'll be really cool there's a lot of
really cool stuff coming this time they start the
trailer with the Watcher telling the story The
Night Before Christmas playing that theme song
like it's all based on Christmas themes to the
night before Christmas with them starting of a
picture of the Avengers Tower in the snow globe
that's probably from the present day what if
happy Hogan Saved Christmas episode there's a lot
of footage from that during this trailer but it's
just one of the episodes that episode I think
is meant to take place inside the 616 Universe
before the events of Avengers Age of Ultron
because the iron Legion exists but we haven't
seen Ultron yet and the whole idea is that after
Avengers Age of Ultron Iron Man got rid of the
iron Legion so to speak then as he continues the
Night Before Christmas you see Thor busting up
a bunch of Ultron bots in New York City with
a bunch of wreckage around them I think this
is actually meant to be from the captain Carter
episode like a completely different episode and
what looks like they're doing is they're saying
that in Captain Carter's episode they're basically
giving her like the original Steve Rogers Captain
America plot something similar to that where she
winds up in present day on a new version of The
Avengers team but in this reality the roster is
meant to be more of a reference to the original
Avengers roster when they debuted in the 1960s
like right after stanlee created the team because
you see wasp on the team and wasp's costume looks
more like the original wasp costume just more
modernized for the most part though all the
other characters are wearing their costumes
from the original first Avengers movie in the
main MCU 616 universe so like a lot of things are
similar with a couple changes in this reality it
also seems like they have accelerated the events
of Ultron like Iron Man has already accidentally
created Ultron so they're battling Ultron in
the Battle of New York instead of Loki with the
scepter the chitauri in Thanos there is a lot of
Thanos in different parts of the trailer like it
seems like he becomes a much bigger overarching
villain later in the episodes I'll talk about him
in a second part of the idea with Captain Carter's
episode in present day is that it becomes more of
a riff on the Captain America Winter Soldier movie
with her skinny boy Steve Rogers being the Winter
Solder in her reality there's a much longer clip
from what seems like episode one what if nebula
joined the Nova cor with her basically going to
a casino space Casino owned by Howard the Duck
Seth Green is back as the voice of the character
he also voices Howard the duck in the liveaction
Guardians of the Galaxy movies there a couple
other cameo scenes too like Tao watiti comes
back is a version of corg Groot is back there's a
version of draxx in the background yelling at the
slot machines and it's supposed to be more of a
Blade Runner space Noir kind of episode then they
have sort of the record scratch moment they jump
back to that what if happy Hogan save Christmas
episode to reveal that it's Justin Hammer inside a
version of the Hulkbuster armor this is obviously
meant to be after the events of the first Avengers
movie after Iron Man 2 so at some point he's
gotten out out of prison somehow part of the idea
though is that all the regular Avengers are not
at the Avengers Tower they're off doing Christmas
based themes like they're all dressed in different
Christmas outfits like iron man is dressed up like
Santa Claus leaving The Avengers Tower a little
bit more vulnerable than usual allowing Justin
Hammer to break in and it just seems like he's
trying to steal everything he can get his hands
on with habby Hogan being the only person there so
they pull a Die Hard with him basically having to
take down Justin hammer and his goons with Darcy's
help and it is Cat Dennings coming back back to
play Darcy zooming in hands on this scene too I
think this is actually from that same episode in
present day like the Happy Hogan episode notice
you see Steve Rogers Captain America arguing with
Bruce Banner's Hulk while he's in his human form
in that ugly Christmas sweater with the symbol of
the atom on it because science Bros and it seems
like they're fighting over the last Iron Man toy
in the toy store just because it's so popular like
it's sold out notice that the Iron Man logo in
the Hawkeye logo are based on their comic book
logos in the scene itself is just meant to be a
PA like a reference to the Arnold Schwarzenegger
movie Jingle All The Way which is a terad movie
but it's a bit of a Christmas tradition where he
basically battles Sinbad over who's going to
get the last remaining Turbo Man toy Before
Christmas like they're joking here and this is
actually pretty true to real life that Iron Man
is super popular like all the kids want the Iron
Man toy they're all grabbing for it nobody wants
Hawkeye's toy because no one really cares about
him he's not that popular so the store here has
had to Discount the price on his toys by 25% to
try and dump like there's only one Hawkeye toy
that's sold this is actually a phenomenon that's
really common to toy stores in real life like if
they want to get rid of a bunch of extra toys
they'll just discount them heavily and if you
think about it here there's only one Hawkeye toy
sold I wouldn't be surprised if it was actually a
younger version of Kate Bishop here because this
is earlier in the timeline who's the only person
in New York who bought a Hawkeye toy she would be
the person who would rather have the Hawkeye toy
instead of the Iron Man toy I'm not sure where
this scene of The Nutcracker is from it might
be from that same episode episode because it does
look kind of like present day this scene of Gamora
just seems like it's from the Iron Man on SAR
episode there's a random scene of Kori this might
actually be from the later teamup episodes not
from her own episode then we see Captain Carter
talking to Supreme strange basically asking
them who their big team up villain is this is
probably from one of those final episodes when
Supreme strange is meant to come back and put
together another Multiverse Avengers team not
totally sure when this killmonger episode is
going to be but he's coming back obviously and it
is Michael B Jord coming back to voice killmonger
again it's not the same killmonger from season 1
there's a real quick Montage of some footage that
we've seen before like Hela from her episode we
see a little bit of Loki wearing his armor from
earlier in the timeline like this is before
the events of the Loki series we did see his
Multiverse tree during the last big trailer so we
do know that they'll reference some moments from
Loki season 2 all these scenes of The Red Skull
seem like they're from the Marvel 1602 episode is
part of all the other Hulk footage that we see
where Hulk is freaking out on all the palace
guards here that's also where this Ant-Man
footage is happening too like it's old timey
Ant-Man and it seems like Red Skull is fighting
a version of Winter Soldier here this footage of
Kori catching Captain Carter's Shield seems like
it's from the later teamup episodes when Supreme
strange is taking her around the Multiverse
recruiting that new Multiverse Avengers team
this scene is actually from the 1980s Avengers
episode where you see them fighting a version
of ego the living planet and a much younger
version of Peter Quill who has his celestial
Powers there's a real quick shot of Bill Foster
Goliath during this going real big this scene
is Odin versus Hela and W woo with the 10 rings
and we get that last little happy Hogan joke like
what could go wrong it's just the holidays even
though the Avengers are gone like what's going to
happen and all of a sudden Justin Hammer shows up
there's a bunch of stuff going on in the footage
here so if you spotted anything that I didn't
talk about in this video or my previous what
if season 2 trailer videos just write it below
in the comments but like I said my episode one
video will post tomorrow it should be up pretty
early in the morning each of the episodes will
drop midnight the night before Pacific time so
just adjust based on whatever time zone you're
in after that I'll probably post my Aquaman
2 post credit scene then my what if Episode
2 video on Saturday so on and so forth I'll update
the schedule in my next couple of videos generally
my what if episodes should post at the same time
every single day though through episode 9 there
are a bunch of other Marvel projects that got
announced recently mostly X-Men based stuff the
next several years like we talk about the mutant
Saga being the next big Saga of Marvel starting
with phase s I'll probably do a separate video
about that just because there's so much stuff
and this video just got a little bit longer than
I wanted it to get make sure you enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss anything click
here for that what if season 2 episode 1 video
I'll update the link as soon as I post that and
click here for that X-Men 97 teaser trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!